the gyro can experience you know what's
the [ __ ] is those 1965's with the
suicide doors come on son you know I'm
never that bold I could not buy one of
those cars you come rolling around in
one of those 1965 Lincoln Continentals
with the suicide doors like holy we
should really want to drive
Dijon Continental see what he drove
Jamie you used to get out and open the
door sideways for whatever his name was
the black beauty Chrysler Imperial crown
beautiful for Wow let me see a picture
of that 1966 Chrysler look at that thing
we're looking at picture one ladies and
gentlemen it looks like it has machine
guns the poke out of the hood well that
missiles that was the black beauty tell
my god that's hilarious but I like I
always like that's a car you had a
[ __ ] car who made that one now that's
a restomod new Green Hornet no the new
one that was the new one with Seth Rogen
right yeah I didn't see that one no no
the one we throw that one look at that
one people don't understand we're a
little too young for it but people don't
understand what an impact Bruce Lee had
when he was doing the Green Hornet when
people saw him do martial arts moves the
way he did on screen like people wanted
I mean you have to think about how many
people would watch a TV show back then
like if you had a TV show there's only
like 30 different things to watch right
like if you had a TV show you had the
entire country watching one of three
things and if you had a big show if The
Green Hornet was the Green Hornet and on
Sunday nights
so was it was like stealing yeah
everyone's home you had you either had
Lawrence Welk on [ __ ] channel seven on
ABC look at these things you didn't see
this looks like I dropped and he just
traumatized NBC NBC was traumatized only
did six episodes look how bad their
[ __ ] fight scenes are
these look at these white guys faking
punches oh my god
it's hilarious to see like old school
bad TV like fight acting like well you
know the punch didn't hit them in the
hair goes flying it's so weird
especially because we're not playing any
of the volume so we're just watching it
so when you're watching with no volume
you get to really see how preposterous
it is how many how many TV shows that
that guy you know that Spanish dude did
about a thousand episodes of different
TV shows from the late 60s all through
the 70s who is he I don't know what he's
the guy that was starring right there
right there that guy you know character
actors were like [ __ ] so huge back
then but then Bruce Lee came on Sunday
nights I still remember driving back
from Miami with my family I like being
pissed because I miss Bruce Lee
then they cancelled it you didn't see
nothing about Bruce Lee again bro how
long was it between that and the big
movies it was about a year and a half
that come for movies were mainstream
five thing as a death came out no the
yeah Five Fingers a debt that was all
about the iron palm technique the guy
would look at you and his pawn would
turn pink and that started with that and
then Fist of Fury came out but I'm not
gonna lie to you and tell you I went to
see Fist of Fury in the movie theater I
don't remember when Chinese connection
came out that's what changed the
ballgame but see it pisses me off today
you know when I see [ __ ] people with
twenty years old talking monkey impact
of Bruce Lee or whatever first off let's
get this straight
Bruce Lee was a tough guy but he wasn't
gonna beat Muhammad Ali that was so
silly he wasn't gonna be Bob Marley he
was you know whatever Bruce Lee Bruce
Lee meant that the little guy had hope
Bruce Lee gave the immigrant hope you
know that's what all these guys all we
[ __ ] it changed everybody put a
little bounce in the step he chose
martial arts he changed martial arts but
he gave you hope the movie theaters were
packed
martial arts schools were packed black
people were going crazy because nobody
suffered anymore
[Applause]